then a portion of what you make i get as
commissioned yeah based off your entire
like
career on only fans it's almost like uh
like
sometimes like i'm with capital one
sometimes you'll be like hey if you get
a referral give a referral or whatever
people sign up you get this much money
is it like that yes
yeah but instead
[Music]
what's your identity in the uk british
no no no
yes but no i was thinking like your
alter ego like a slim shady oh like a
like a punk rocker yeah but what's
what's his name
you're joking though right you're not
gonna drop neil niels niels neal where
are we rolling yeah we're rolling oh
well don't catch after dark hundreds as
i was saying 100 okay 100 what over
recording is that counter going up on
the uh audio yes sir all right perfect
oh that means we're doing it we're doing
it we're doing the damn thing yeah we
were talking about fighting mm-hmm i
want to talk about chance tattoo you
guys already talked about it huh no no
i said no nicky i said on the podcast
yeah on the podcast do you see us nick
though
is it there uh it's uh it's the hdmi
it's not plugged in oh okay okay yeah
hdmi
it's a great shot too yeah what is it
so i told you guys about this before i
want to get a tattoo
or my entire body tattooed but this is
like a magpie birds that are the
national bird of korea yeah and then
also cherry blossoms my parents love
cherry blossoms so
you know
i wanted to do something with cherry
blossoms eventually
thank you still healing it's going to
take a while yeah how many sessions were
was that one sit down that took all day
that's what i'm saying i was like yeah
you look like you do that one sitting
also
what's cool is uh
um
what's cool about you in that tattoo is
like i feel like you've already had it
like it's already been there i feel like
yeah you didn't notice it yeah yeah
cause it's like it just looks so natural
like i expect you to have like
a sleeve of some sort
you know what i mean that's cool is that
fair yeah i might like everything i like
the fact that you think that i should
already have a sleeve yeah all right but
i feel kate i want you guys opinion
because you guys have tattoos who else
has tattoos george does george has a
bunch of tattoos nick has zero huh we're
getting one
i have i've none after after this i'll
tell you my plan for my tattoo that i've
had for 10 years i heard [ __ ] stamps
are coming back in i don't think that's
can you imagine the woman
of all things yeah based off his energy
i don't know
it's like chewie's face too just like
what if it's like the old school like
2000 barbed wire but it's like
trampoline oh yeah the bar the pam
anderson
my grandma has a tattoo on her ankle of
my old dog cody
that's kind of when she was like 84.
look at these [ __ ] stamps once it's
trump
go to that one
a trump stamp that's a layer
exactly
dude that is hilarious that's true good
oh my god
uh right uh second row on the far left
oh the seconds right there there you go
that is freaking hilarious
if you had to guess
based off majority of these
females in this in these photos white
well uh obviously obviously
obviously orange obviously oh yeah
i said where's the turtle
orange county where's their location
orange county i like how there's so many
trump stamps oh that's just because you
hit that picture yeah so chin are you
gonna go back to ireland and be like
what's up now man tap my [ __ ] neck
yeah oh my god you should yeah you
should since i have at least two tattoos
now like one big one and one small one
from ireland i think yeah at this point
they have to let me tattoo my neck yeah
that'd be messed up they don't what's up
the question i asked you is i feel it's
so empty here yeah this area
yeah do you think i should fill it up
with something or just leave it out
that's exactly how i felt when i just
had the snake and then i start adding to
it and the more i looked at my arm the
more i felt like it looks empty now that
something's there so it only felt right
to get a sleeve
adding stuff yeah that's the addiction
of tattoos right there you get one
little one and you're like well i need
it on the other side and then you do
that and you're like well every time i
get a tattoo i need more and more yeah
yeah and if you trust your artist your
artist will guide you
on a you know what what to what to like
fill it with you know to kind of
accommodate to the whole
thing itself but yeah you got a lot of
canvas
i do i think so um
go ahead dog go up all right man i know
you are get the knuckles done stop
playing that's okay so georgie has his
knuckles done i can't imagine getting my
knuckles done
what does he say the the the dj for
slipknot his his knuckles uh say must
kill
that's kind of dope yeah yeah somebody's
gone
you should kill the game it's like it's
like for comedy killing you know you
must kill and then i just at the end of
my set yeah don't bomb oh don't bother
don't don't you don't oh that fits yeah
bomb yeah ooh don't fumble yeah just to
remind myself i was just like yeah so uh
yeah
you're in the mirror just like don't
bomb don't bomb don't bother oh yeah in
the mirror that's how i do it
what was your first one george my very
first tattoo professionally was this big
what a great sentence because that means
there is an unprofessional one someplace
on his body yeah but my upper thighs
because i was 16 and then it went mommy
to see
uh no i my buddy did it when i was very
drunk off of captain morgan in his
kitchen you were a wild child wild boy
[Laughter]
rum ought to do that
morgan 16.
put a little hair on your chest yes sir
there's a lot of hair on your head but
my first professional tattoo was this
anchor lighthouse on my arm which my
tattoo artist just passed away today oh
no
yeah there's alright alright ricky
but
right here yeah serendipity took like
four or five hours
but ricky took a smoke break in the
middle so probably didn't take that long
you know four and a half ish yeah yeah
he kept hitting on my sister the whole
time
yeah
pretty fun
ricky was also a wild boy he was also
one boy yep
wait what's your plan
uh so my favorite book
is the old man the sea by ernest
hemingway can you look up uh
uh marlin illustration old man the sea
and i've always said like after i like
was like comfortable where i'm at got
all my bills taken care of
and get ripped that's like basically the
only thing holding me up now
i got all the other stuff
we're good i get ripped i want to get uh
this illustration down my down my side
as well
because the old man to see is all about
like learning from your mistakes
overcoming
uh
yeah learning from your mistakes
essentially and yeah down in your ribs
everybody said it's the most
i got raw power tattooed on my
[ __ ] uh what do you call this
clavicles clavicles could you look that
up jordan yep oh cool i don't know where
is it at um
yeah if you go just go old man to see
illustration that seems like a [ __ ]
actually it seems like it'd be [ __ ]
painful so you didn't put any numbing
cream
nothing no
did they offer you no
i i did for my stomach but it kind of i
don't know it's weird numbing cream i
think it depends on the person yeah
for me it kind of
it worked a little bit but it was it
wore off like it does work
so it's like
almost kind of pointless you kind of
just got to go through it
and just take the the pain because i
mean once yeah once you're done you're
done you know but i mean the pain
and the pain's kind of cool in a way
right i think we no i don't know
[ __ ] no no i hate every tattoo
it doesn't suck but it's also kind of
like because you know you can take it
you know you can like get through it oh
no it's not my tattoo artist i didn't
let her shade the inside of my arm i was
like nah what i'm leaving
yeah she didn't finish the
technically because um yeah right right
here
no one's gonna see this [ __ ] and so she
wanted to shade it in i was like i'm
physically going to hit you if you touch
my arm
outline it but you don't want to shake
shake shake shake shake shake shake
shake
shake
shake
shake
shake
shake shake shake share and subscribe the
shading would have been fun i love the
shading i hate did it get did it hurt
shading is fine yeah oh my god the elbow
hurts
it looks dumb thanks hey get the shading
done just use the numbing cream uh no
she does not use numbing cream yeah yeah
some artists don't use it just because
they say that uh your skin gets kind of
spongy like the texture slightly changes
so
one year from now no not a year like
wait six months six months start today
searching you could get because you're
not like you ain't you you ain't got no
pudge too yeah you're like yeah you can
get ripped
honestly
the pudge is gonna take some of the pain
away tattoos at 451 pounds compared to
190 pounds felt so good
hey he can say that yeah he's going to
say that he knows exactly
so you should get fat nick that is what
you should we out here getting skinny
tattoos
you know
he's done both we need thick cats yeah
and i do have thick tet i have
on my i got
the dough yeah they don't know freaking
i know those are really tight pants
george you were padded up he's got
everywhere thick smiley face over here
cute okay show off what in the world wow
[Laughter]
i'm challenging stevie weeby to jiu
jitsu next time all right that's crazy
you you always win that nibble yeah i
think even when i was giant i could
still do crazy [ __ ] that's about us
that's awesome
it's weird oddly enough and it's only
because i've coached cheer and like all
this [ __ ] i could just tell that you're
really flexible based off of your body
oh yeah and i don't mean that in like
you know
like a gay way yeah i mean that's
totally uh
you know
straight male that was a cheerleading
coach
uh no you can tell you're still i'm i'm
pretty flexible huh just try to put your
leg up there let's see
oh that's really flexible
[Laughter]
a kid could walk in
okay he is flexible he is so flexible
there you go what the freak
i'm telling you oh my god
no way seems like a kid could walk in
and i don't just tell
their skills right off the bat by just
about how they walk i go you're not
going to be good
you ever thought about
football but also that's a shitty thing
for me to say because people didn't
think i would be good at cheerleading
mm-hmm they told they were like oh
he'll probably never be good and then i
was like [ __ ] what you're like
i'm great and then i i took what is what
did jordan say what does he say huh and
i took that person
again
i was that guy though i took a lot of
[ __ ] personal when it came to people
telling me i couldn't do something
that's how you got so good great driver
it's a great motivator yeah what
probably not the healthiest but uh it
works i do it in a healthy short time i
do it in a healthy way you still use it
you still use it oh yeah
uh but i'm just real quiet about it
yeah yeah were you loud about it before
that's uh
yeah
were you loud about it before
uh or did you just kind of like silently
hold on no i think i'd be like man [ __ ]
you watch me get better than your [ __ ]
ass yeah that was me but now but now i'm
like yeah
now that's your internal monologue
yeah yeah no now i just go
okay all right
but yeah that's getting quiet and then
all of a sudden
it just happens out of nowhere and then
people are like oh i probably shouldn't
have i probably should have never said
that about him yeah so they're just the
same you're just more zen about it yeah
because of
magic mind yeah so if i had magic mind
when i was younger i probably would have
been as aggressive but since i have
magic mine now it makes me not as
aggressive but it keeps my focus and
then i just go out and kick ass silently
yeah the ashwagandha really
does wonder i can't wait to go to
ashwagandha it's beautiful this time
i always really worry about those like
alternate timelines like
i'm glad you didn't find this when you
were younger because you wouldn't be
here today probably and then we want to
be doing this you know i do give a lot
of credit to all my crazy [ __ ] back in
the day
if you didn't do all that crazy [ __ ]
though [ __ ] i'd be a nerd
there's a lot of good country songs
about like what could have happened your
church has one called what i almost was
oh yeah darius rucker has one called
don't think i don't think about no
that's kind of one but he's like every
stoplight i didn't like everything i did
there's a song that's actually called
what could have been by little texas
yeah a lot of country songs do yeah yeah
yeah they yeah
yeah i probably have a boring ass story
yeah you know i probably wouldn't be
much to it no life i think yeah i think
all the crazy [ __ ] i [ __ ] i'm like
thank you [ __ ] yeah
but you can just quick let me wrap it up
no you can all alter your future at
magicmind.com
use promo code dark for 20 off thank you
so much
i was looking for your name
[Laughter]
chappelle's episode of below the line
with james beshear that was a great
conversation i'm excited i was i was so
caught off guard i just didn't know that
man gets deep
and uh i think he might have said this
last week but he he would ask me
questions about things that i've never
really thought about before and then
realize i was aware of
until
until that conversation
you know what i mean it was it was
really [ __ ] dope i'm like man i've
never been asked that i was like i've
never really thought that
you know deeply about that specific
point but i but but i knew how to answer
it because
i think just kind of
just was able
to do something
mainly off the knowledge that i had and
it's hard for a professional podcaster
to say the sentence i've never been
asked that or i've never talked about
that before you know this is your life
all you do is talk listen
i turned down a lot of podcasts
and a lot of the reason is because i get
asked the same question
all the [ __ ] time like this it's like
all in the same
like way how did you get into comedy
how did you become a cheerleader
how did you start playing guitar like
it's like the same [ __ ] questions and
it drives me crazy there's a lot of bad
podcasts out there who don't know how to
interview but do you ever think about it
as like even though it's like boring
like i'm exposing myself and giving
these same answers to a new audience who
then becomes chappelle fans
um
i mean i feel like i've done so many to
where like you could just easily and
you're not even feeling that it really
moved the needle no not no not at all no
i mean i saw that james's podcast like i
was like holy [ __ ] that's like i don't
think i've ever really been asked that
kind of question there's there's some
people that are like really good to
where i'm like oh [ __ ] like they'll talk
to me about cheerleading but they'll ask
specific questions that no one ever has
like usually the common question is like
oh did you you know [ __ ]
you know
[ __ ] grab ass and [ __ ] like that and
i'm like
[ __ ]
yes
but it's just it's a [ __ ]
i don't know it's just such a generic
surface level
kind of question where i like okay
but i would love to ask you about
appleton wisconsin all day
i've never been so
not appleton lacrosse lacrosse
[ __ ] i had a question for cat yeah okay
here we go what's up so you you got your
booming only fans business
have you thought of ways to scale this
how to expand because i have an idea oh
my god yes please
you could be like an only fan's pimp
like find girls who you think would be
good at only fans get them to start only
fans and then you collab on yours and be
like hey check out [ __ ] leticia
yeah
people actually the t-shirt sounds hot
yeah and that's why
it sounds
come on
if you're listening thoughts yeah well
people actually do this on a different
level because girls at the beginning of
only fans a lot of girls started to
glamorize the lifestyle which like
granted it did work only fans does work
out for a good amount of people and
helps them make money where they
otherwise probably wouldn't have had
been able to make that much from
something as simple as just posting
photos or videos of yourself
but girls would
promote this like only fans lifestyle
online particularly i saw on tick tock a
lot and there's a lot of young
impressionable girls on there like oh
like i can now make a bunch of money
really quickly like these young 18 19
year old girls and they say like oh use
my referral link to sign up and i'll
help you out and what that does is that
so if i'm on only fans and i give you my
referral link and you want to sign up
for only fans then a portion of what you
make i get as commission yeah based off
your entire like
career on only fans it's almost like a
like
sometimes like i'm with capital one
sometimes it's like hey if you get a
refer give a referral or whatever people
sign up you get this much money is it
like that yeah
yeah but instead
yes but instead of like a flat fee it
continues so like there's not a point
where i will ever stop making money off
of you if you're making money on only
fans okay question so that's what it is
when that percentage that you get from
that person is that coming out because
like eight only fans is 80 20 right yeah
80 20. does that come out of their 80 or
is that coming out only fans is 20. i am
not sure i was told that it comes out of
only fans is 20 not your 80. yeah that
would make more sense because like
otherwise a girl would just see a
referral link be like i'm not going to
dip out of my [ __ ] i'll just go that is
a good idea but i'm not clicking but a
lot of but a lot of people didn't know
that at first initially because i think
i was watching like a
a youtube drama channel oh of the
e-pimps have only damn i thought he
invented like a whole new
no
people do this quite often yeah uh it's
i think it's definitely harder to do
that now because only fans are so
heavily saturated the the move for you
to do that would then to be like
bringing someone who already has a huge
following in to do only fans rather than
like the random like oh girl from
i don't know like lacrosse who's just
like oh i want to make some extra money
so do you feel like you got in at a good
time because it is so oversaturated now
i think i got in kind of later to the
game the only reason why i think i made
a good living off of only fans is
because i am on podcasts i i think i
have a very special situation where i am
being seen every single week
people
see more of my personality online than
they would like a random instagram model
because a lot of instagram models they
you don't even know what their voices
sound like you see a lot of photos of
them videos but you don't even know what
they sound like whereas with me you can
tune in every single week i'm on fire in
the kid or oh so they have the network
there's like yeah there's a
i feel like there's a closer bond so the
engagement's already a lot stronger than
say like a regular instagram model but
on top of that i also have a very large
male demographic from the podcast a lot
of girls who make a lot of money on
instagram and do sponsorships with
fashion nova and stuff like that they
usually have a very large female
demographic
and women who have a large female
demographic usually don't make that much
money on only fans because that's more
of a like
male consumed site
so it really just depends you got no
lesbians following you i have a few yeah
i've seen a few but it really doesn't
it's like a very small drop in the
bucket in comparison to them they got
that high and tight here yeah but like
no oh my god there was no there's this
one girl i don't wanna
there's this one girl i don't wanna say
her name because i don't wanna like out
anyone who's like on my only fans but do
we know her no no you don't it's just
like a random girl who watches the
podcast who subscribe so [ __ ] pretty
so
[ __ ] pretty i was looking at her
phone like
why are you you want girl she does
no no she follows me
i was like you are a bad [ __ ]
like jesus christ because she sent me a
photo
very pretty
i don't have the phone but like
imagine this looks like keilani
david i'm okay lonnie the singer
i don't know who came out i think
kailani is beautiful so like she reminds
me of k lonnie and i i just think she's
so pretty good luck on spelling it bro i
think k k e h
l a and i who gets it
looks like k lonnie oh there you are
good job george
is she a solo artist kayla yeah she's a
r b solo artist
okay she's oh she dates yj cute uh she
used to be with yg
but
yeah i think kailani is beautiful okay
and she reminds me of keilani very
beautiful life is not attractive
yeah i can hear you i hear you
over there
but she's cute i can tell when people
are cute also has a very specific taste
yeah
and that's fine yeah which is fine it's
just like this isn't his like yeah his
speed
i get it but yeah go to that one to the
hotline she looks really pretty there
yeah she has a baby oh that's cute which
one would you like chapel uh the one
word like to the top go to the top uh to
the right
right there
that one yeah
so look at it's the lighting
i think she's very pretty she's also
from the bay area so i have like a
bias oh okay okay no that's fair yeah
that's fair shout out to kailani shout
out to kayla hopefully she'll come on
one day and we'll mm-hmm i'll sit in
chat you know she was uh mentored by
nick cannon nope she's one of those
people yes i know a lot of people
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] on the canon but that
dude kills it
behind the scenes he's helped so many
people show me where he's failed
people only count on him because he
can't rap
there are some instances
there was one fail look okay it's a big
fail listen i like i like his raps
let's just say you wouldn't have been a
fan of last week's episode with ari
manis
[Laughter]
sorry yes okay okay okay but yeah he's
cool i forgot about that i forgot about
that i'm sorry i forgot about that i i i
totally forgot about this situation
chappelle which which rap
do i like i like his uh i like the
gigolo song do you like the jigglypuff
yeah uh what's he's got this other one
uh hold on
where is it
he's got gigolo there's another one
[ __ ] what's it has the um
billboard devoe sample
is driving me out of my gosh what is
that [ __ ] song called okay but i like
those two songs
okay
and then uh i like his movies damn
movies yes movies are great
i'm just going to bug me with that song
drum line
and he's been killing out for
what since i was 18 years old he had his
own show on uh nickelodeon yep he's been
killing it for a minute for a long time
i think people only make fun of him now
because of the like his music career the
eminem thing and the fact that he's a
lot of kids but he wants a lot of people
and he takes care of all of his kids
oh he does
he's he's a what do you call it
polygamous
is that what they call it i don't know
[Laughter]
i thought it was like a religious thing
mormon no as to why he does all this
[ __ ] i mean there's a lot of religions
that do the multiple wives i don't think
it's just the mormon jehovah's witness i
don't know damn it whatever he's not
what's he like islam
no that's not islam
islam i thought he he
yeah that's a mormon thing like muslim i
know i thought he converted i know they
don't have multiple wives will you look
up how long he's been doing walling out
well it stops for a while yeah it took a
hiatus and then he brought it back
polyamorous
paulie is that what he's is that what he
was playing i saw the article and said
yeah but that's not like linked to
religion well that's polyamorous
it can be a part of yeah it can be you
not always but yeah
um i mean eddie murphy got a lot of kids
but he's not like [ __ ]
he just got a lot of kids
yeah
there's this one part in chappelle show
way back in the day yeah when uh
he was like i don't know his kid was
like watching nick cannon he's watching
like wilder out yeah he's like he's like
man what are you watching he's like
he's like nick cannon he's like [ __ ]
mccannon she's like i love nick can he's
hilarious
so the first was 2005 yeah july 20 2005
i was 18.
and influential yeah influential and
then the series has been through
how many
uh has been renewed for through 16
seasons
16 seasons
and then they took a break for some
point we should have a wild now episode
of cats after dark i haven't watched it
so i don't know the structure but it's
basically like joke
oh yeah
who we introduced
who we introduced
use the teacher's name
it was so funny because my manager hit
me up uh
and he was like because i already know
the answer but i just have to ask he
goes walling out i said no
you didn't even want the opportunity to
audition no no no no no no no no no
no no i love that you say no to things i
was just thinking i say no to a lot of
because i'm like listen
the reason why i say no to a lot of [ __ ]
is because i want to deliver my best and
if it's something that i don't like i
know one thousand percent i won't
deliver my best then i'll be known as a
guy that's kind of difficult to work
with you know so i was like if i if i
don't want to do something i'm sure it's
not gonna [ __ ] do it yeah i'll just
be like okay because i'd rather have the
freedom and my [ __ ] sanity more than
anything yeah and if i just don't want
to be a part of something i'm like i
ain't [ __ ] doing it
you know what i mean
i don't know think about that mind [ __ ]
when you do [ __ ]
that you don't [ __ ] like i feel so
like i hate at school yeah and think
about why the [ __ ] am i here
who
do everything and
they say yes to everything then
but that's just nick saying it's not
about you i know but the man's a warrior
the man is the worker he takes but
here's the thing here's the thing that's
what that's what's crazy like i have
some friends
gosh i hate even saying this because i
don't even want to sound arrogant
because it'll come off arrogant and then
people be in the comments like supposed
to [ __ ] here again um so i'll try to
say it as best as i can without of any
arrogance okay
um
i know people that say a l uh yes to a
lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] like i have some
homies that are you know of of my
caliber we're all you know pretty much
the same level and they say yes to a lot
of [ __ ] nah i wouldn't even say with the
same level [ __ ] all right this is
horrible see now that's arrogant that
right there that's it
start starting
is like
i've seen people say yes to a lot of
[ __ ] and i've and i've seen them just
struggle along the way whereas like i
feel
like i've been able to do what all that
i want and i feel like i'm able to grow
because i do say no
um that's what i'm trying to say yeah
i think that i think i think that makes
a lot like it's hard for people to grow
when they just say yes to everything
because
now they're doing anything without any
sort of
meaning of feeling behind it
and then they become a backup because
they're like oh we know we could get
whoever they'll say yes yes whereas you
they're like oh we better [ __ ] let
them know it's like yeah it's like when
you're like single people smell the
desperation but you're in a relationship
yes yes yes yes i mean i've turned down
some stuff where people like are you
insane i go no i just know i wouldn't do
that
i just don't want to do that like i
don't think i'm insane as much as i am
that's beautiful man that's people more
sane you know it's just it's just
[ __ ]
you don't have to say yes to [ __ ]
i don't know and i get it because it's
tough it's tough to feel that way
because obviously we're in the industry
of people trying to do some [ __ ] so
you know you feel like when opportunity
comes you're like oh yeah i'll take it
you know what i don't know
i can't do that i think it's very
evident that you don't make decisions
out of fear of not working whereas i
think a lot of people in the industry do
because i don't know when the next time
i'm gonna get like this opportunity to
work
do a job where i'm seeing in front of a
camera i might as well just take it now
maybe it'll lead to something else yeah
and i just go whereas you you're like i
don't want to do this thing so i'm just
gonna pass on it if i don't get
something else it's fine i'll figure it
out yeah meanwhile i get to do a lot of
[ __ ]
i get to do so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm sure and i've turned down cities
what city tell me my residence
i go i would never want to go there
oh is this your boy is this our boy i
believe can you hear us
hey how you doing hi
so this is one of this is someone from
where wait where specifically
i'm in london you're london
are you coming to my show
i'm at the show i'll be there i've got
my tickets
that makes me happy
yeah
that's awesome
uh
so chris you're in london
i'll be there
when the [ __ ] i leave tomorrow so you'll
be there wednesday okay so yeah i'll be
there wednesday
okay
and
what's there to [ __ ] do
what's there to do
well um i don't know if you know so this
this coming week is uh
it's a big like celebration for the
royal family the queen's uh 70th uh
platinum jubilee so it's going to be
very busy in london when you're there
i'll warn you now oh wow that it's it's
his 70th jubilee show yeah
i knew all that yeah i'm i'm well aware
of the history of uh
jubilee you know what i'm saying shout
out to jubilee
yeah so uh so so that'll be happening
there'll be lots of stuff happening
around london because of that um so
it'll be pretty busy
um but no there's uh there's loads of
stuff to do i sent you um the link about
the oasis album cover yep
yep so one of oasis album covers there's
a specific spot where they sorry uh took
the picture of it and he told me where
the spot was and it's not too far from
where i'm performing right yeah it's
like five minutes down the road yeah
damn dude so you're recreating that you
have a record oh yeah
i'm recreating that photo for sure
you're gonna have jay take the photo for
you yeah how's the food amazing
it feels good yeah it feels good it's
good see people be talking [ __ ] maybe
saying food ain't amazing there i hear
you [ __ ] it's not you guys in
this room
i would have said that if fast though
and it was [ __ ] i
that's all i've heard i've never been
obviously but everybody says it's bland
and boring and it depends what sort of
food you want i would say is there a lot
of vegan options
there's a few yeah there's a few um
there's um
lewis hamilton has like a vegan
restaurant yes he's yours yeah so i'd
recommend that i've eaten there before
that's good oh wow dude i can't dude i'm
about to get lit dude
how are the pubs
the pubs are good yeah there's lots of
lots of bars
he's out there but i would love to like
experience it i'll probably last like 10
minutes in there because it might get
round
they get rowdy huh
and it's not too bad unless it gets late
in the evening then it might get a bit
rowdy well how long do your pubs stay
open till
um
probably till like midnight on average
oh really that's it yeah
oh yeah pubs like just pubs would be
midnight but then if you go into like a
bar the bars will probably be open till
like one two in the morning okay okay
okay clubs again a bit later so yeah
damn that's crazy wait so when because
we our shut off drinking
hours are from like what two to
two to six or something to six a.m
weird like that
yeah do you guys have cut off hours for
being able to purchase alcohol yeah so
in in pubs they do this thing called
last orders where they'll like ring a
bell behind the bar and that's like the
last chance to go and order a drink and
then they play closing time by
semi-sonic that's what they do here yeah
that's what they do yeah it's the
standard here in america
very standard have you been to the
states
yeah yeah call up oh oh [ __ ] damn he
knows a lot about us
it's time for you to learn about them is
there anything chappelle should know
about like what he shouldn't do while
he's in london so he doesn't look like
an [ __ ]
um
in in central london near near where the
club is and a lot around there there's
just a lot of like very obviously like
touristy type things tourist traps
almost just avoid those i would say okay
they're quite obvious
i'm gonna look like i'm from there
yeah yeah blended yeah i'm gonna blend
the [ __ ] in i don't know i'm gonna just
get a bunch of adidas gear
yeah right
no no oh don't do that
if chappelle just wears his normal
attire he's wearing uh jeans and an
oasis i know that's gonna be if you fit
in perfectly he'll fit in oh okay then
that's easy be perfect yeah
if you were to guess how many oasis
t-shirts i have what would you say
well i'm gonna guess what 10 15.
that's cute
he said 10 or 15.
try 25.
25 okay i mean he was in the ballpark
actually i don't know i know it's more
than more than 20.
i have so many oasis shirts
wait are you going to see liam
no no are you not an oasis man
i'm an oasis fan okay i haven't got
tickets
will they play don't look back and anger
in the bars and in the pubs
yeah you'll hear it probably like no it
won't you'd need to like request it but
you they'd play it for you yeah cause
i'll belt it out
yeah
i'll build it out so loud
under karaoke bar and you can do it okay
oh i was
yeah
they do karaoke out there yeah damn okay
i feel like they do karaoke in most
parts of the world yeah they do yeah all
right well fair this is all fair enough
i think i think i got a lot of uh
information and i'm ready yeah any any
last messages forum
must knows must-haves
ways he won't get pick-pocketed
no you should be okay not getting
pick-pocketed it's not too bad um good
cause i'll kick someone's ass
oh i believe
that yeah no um
you've got to have fish and chips while
you're in england so try fish and chips
the classic english meal yeah
all right well thanks brother if you're
any indication his trip is going to be
absolutely electric
thank you so much that that's gonna be
dope i can't wait to see the outfit yeah
and i'll see i'll see you thursday at my
show yeah i'll see you make sure you
come say hi man yeah all right chris is
it chris right guys yeah chris yeah you
being in a bringing a bridge big group
out i can talk
no just me and uh one of my family
members so yeah
right on that's awesome nice to meet you
chris yeah thanks for coming on thanks
for coming on brother i'll see you
thursday he said cheers
oh my god you have to come back and
start calling people your mates oh i
will
say your friends yeah yeah my i mean my
whole lingo is gonna [ __ ] change you
gotta pretend like you're one of those
college students who goes abroad for
like a month and comes back with a
slight accent yeah you know
it's like oh that means
he's already doing it as soon as he
talks to someone that is from england or
london he's like that's all right yeah
is that right
[Laughter]
come to the show
i mean listen you can handle me all you
want for loving
uh a place i've never been before but
you know what the fact that i get to go
is gonna be it's gonna be dope dude
how long are you going for
uh tuesday to monday oh that'll be fun
yeah what's the weather like right now
uh i think it's a little chilly
that's awesome i know it's perfect yeah
in my mind england is always always cool
whether it's 50 cloudy and a little rain
yeah i never know i don't imagine what
does it say
oh you're right you're right geez look
at that
well that's what
presentation
cloudy little rain so that friday the
day i go see liam it's nice it's uh
you have the best sign right yeah you
have the best days
the sun comes out for your two important
days
have you linked up with jack shore
no not yet yeah you guys wait no he i
think he's i don't think he's near
london
i just think everything's close i think
he was going to the
to the concert
his only depending on whether or not
going to concert was if he got his fight
right yeah his fight was actually
yeah yes he has a fight that's booked
i don't know i think he's still he's not
on the london card i think he might be
on the paris card
i forgot what happened to his fight
again because then he posted oh yeah
[ __ ]
um
ricky simone yeah that's that's a big
[ __ ] that's it that's july
16th yeah july 17 16.
this
is where's that fight at maybe this
might be his last i think paris
is it yup no at ufc london no no no no
no
where is this at
uh
no i thought he wasn't doing london no
that was the last london card that
they had a headliner for july 16th yet
to be confirmed okay so i guess
they don't have a place for it but yeah
so i think yes ufc july 16 let me look
speaking of magpies you ever been to
magpies
uh isn't it a soft-serve place in silver
lake i used to pass by a lot i've never
been i heard it's good come on
see yeah that's the spot you love your
silver like spots that's so like vegan
hippie yep it is and i would never live
in silver lake why i couldn't do it it's
just too congested for me it is very
congested right now it's rome yeah yeah
i like the romance
grab some food yeah and i don't mind
congestion but like
not like that
yeah that i feel like that's why i left
la in general i feel like i needed to
roam yeah so i only want to go and walk
that's a new york um
i think eventually i'll probably move
somewhere like in the valley because the
valley doesn't seem as congested yeah
the valley is great i used to live in
burbank and glendale so burbank crips
is that thing i don't know if they're
out there
i heard that if you
[Laughter]
i heard that uh burbank is one of those
towns where if there's a homeless person
there police officers will pick them up
and like drop them off at the outskirts
because there's like technically no
homeless people allowed in the city of
burbank yeah so they'll like drop them
off in glendale so is that okay okay
is that like weird because i know people
like listen
homelessness i mean there's a big
problem in l.a
but is it weird that like
that's a thing i don't know i don't like
because some people say it's rude or
whatever but i also i think it's
extremely rude that we just let them
live
on the street like that i think that's
almost like inhumane yeah right am i
tripping no i know what you're saying
wait no yeah hey listen he names his he
names his homeless people yeah he's got
weight yeah
he's got his thoughts
he's talked about this before there's
just no solution to the zombie zombie
problem yep that's what it is
but i actually got this video sent uh to
me today this is my buddy pat who i do
the podcast with another podcast show
but uh he lives in north hollywood owns
a house supposed to be a nice
neighborhood a little close to the
freeway but uh
this was just today you can you play
this george yes sir
this homeless person was in there they
have their front uh fenced in because
they're doing work in the back so they
let their dogs out and she was like
within
the fence
you're on my property
his wife was filming she goes you think
you're better than me because you have
money or what she's like you're on my
property yeah oh wow
and they have a one and a half year old
little girl so not the most comforting
feeling
pat texted that video and he said uh
this this just happened going to the
encampment under the bridge with a
baseball bat
and then like he didn't he doesn't mean
it no oh
he did a younger pat definitely would
have 15 minutes later he's like i cooled
down i called the police and filed a
police report they won't do anything so
yeah yeah there's no solution i don't
really have thoughts on it like you know
i agree it's a little humane just people
living out
they don't accept help they won't go
into places where you have to be drug
tested and [ __ ] so i don't know there's
there's been like neighborhoods of tiny
houses built that are just sitting empty
oh wait they have wait if they want to
like live in like a homeless like
facility or something they have to get
drug tested there's so much i don't
think there's somebody have drugs
with you there and you can't be using
while you're living there and some
people are like oh [ __ ] that i'm i'd
rather be outside but still be able to
do drugs that's how i was like amsterdam
[Laughter]
you know you guys know me i never built
or anything like that i try not to do
that kind of stuff but that just
organically came out and i did not mean
that yeah you're usually a little more
posh
i don't know if posh is a good thing
though if you're over in the uk
well i am posh
i tried i tried i really wanna try it
right there
i feel like posh isn't your vibe though
no
you think they got a lot of zombies out
there
uh i don't know
but
how can i remember too if i saw like a
bunch of homeless people there i think
there's definitely homeless people there
but nothing like here yeah
how'd you guys come over with the terms
of zombie
uh i don't think uh it's honestly an
original i mean they're they're on bath
and they just kind of like wander about
yeah
we started categories in the zombies i
will take credit for that and you got
the screamer zombies yeah on your corner
oh like zombieland yeah more down your
block right on the corner there
it's intense oh i call that place uh
there's one place it's right off the
101. yeah
i was told by somebody that lots of
times
under
the bridges that's where like gangs will
set up camps and because police don't
bother the homeless so they'll do
they'll go live there like they're
homeless and have gang activity and this
one specific bridge i want to walk under
they have just a multi-room tarp tent
it's a mansion there's drake blasting
out of there when i'm playing people
rolling up on bikes talking all the time
i call it club freeway
and uh i want to infiltrate club freeway
i'm going to come with adderall and try
to befriend them and then you're going
to be please don't get stabbed
yeah next you know he's general manager
[Laughter]
we start having guests who are a part of
that club yeah exactly
like this is bob yeah yeah i met him at
club freeway i was like i got you guys
on the list yeah why are you sure
i've never seen anything like it because
i mean coming from arizona i mean and
you know what to be honest it's kind of
hard to be homeless in arizona it's just
so hot oh gosh
like it's just too damn hot so i i mean
we don't get many actually in the winter
time
what they'll do
is um i don't know if they still do this
but
there was a period of time in the winter
time you'd see a lot of homeless is
because they would bust them basically
from
like the midwest or you know
colder areas yeah and bust them down uh
for free right for free they would just
drop them and then they would just get
off the bus and then they'd just be they
do that to people
yeah in hawaii too where i forgot what
state it was but i was told when i was
younger that there was a state with a
lot of like homeless people in a
concentrated area they didn't know what
to do with them so they bought them a
one-way ticket to hawaii because it's so
livable there weather-wise it is that
they started shipping all these homeless
people to hawaii and suddenly hawaii was
just like wait what the [ __ ] where are
all these people coming from so do you
think i have an extreme homelessness
they have a really good hardest crisis
really yes i think the state of hawaii
ended up suing because of it
yeah you can't just do that yeah you
can't do that [ __ ]
that's not right with free
yeah
it's so crazy you all sitting next to
that [ __ ] on the plane though
but there's nothing like this buy out
like one spear airline flight just like
okay it has to be spirit i feel like
it's spiritual yeah they're definitely
finding spirits that or southwest at
best
but frontier frontier yeah i'll go
frontside frontier
i would go frontier spirit
those are the two that they're taking
southwest a little bit more classy yeah
that's more classy a little bit a little
bit yeah a little bit more a little not
much not much but a little but
spirit
frontier terrible yeah i definitely know
those two are the cheapest but i feel
like when people start naming shitty
airlines every airline gets named what
what do you consider like
not
you're like southwest is a little better
like what do you fly that's good oh i
fly american all the time american
knowledge i feel like americans good
delta is good
i love jetblue too but they never have
like they basically they basically only
have like coast to coast they don't have
the minneapolis i've never seen yeah
yeah they don't have many
uh as far as where they travel to i
think they're trying to get that mint
money the jet blue mint where people
will pay extra to have like a bed
you know i love you you know i don't
know what they do sometimes it's like i
remember i booked a flight through jet
blue
but the flight was american that
happened to me once
i showed up to jetblue they're like oh
no no you're your flight's at american
like we technically own i think they own
that airline too oh like oh we just sent
you over there like well yeah
yeah yeah don't do that yeah exactly no
they they straight up do that yeah
i was so confused i almost missed my
flight cause i'm just kidding they're i
mean they're nice it's cool because you
can go up and get up like uh they have
that thing in the middle on jetblue
where
they have all the snacks and [ __ ] you
can go up there and grab your own snacks
oh yeah so you get their little brownie
bites after they do their like little
run through
they have their baskets still there
but if you want some more you can walk
your ass up there yeah if you want
seconds you're gonna know [ __ ] yeah you
don't have to damn they i always feel i
always feel bad whenever i have to hit
that
i i feel so bad
but i know it's their job but i still
feel bad
i don't think i've ever used it i've
never done anything oh so i'm oh i'm
boujee
um
well there's times where i've been
asleep yeah when they do the oh and you
still want your snapchat yeah
yeah yeah that's cool that's awesome
oh yeah what the [ __ ] is that
i just
flew on american airlines to go to
philadelphia with brendan and the whole
crew
and i thought for sure because it's a
five something hour or
to get there's like four hours something
to get back is fire or something
but i thought for sure they have tvs on
it but they didn't have tvs on it they
didn't have tvs
i was like i don't think that's going to
do to me
because you i remember thinking that we
had the snacks and like you know
whatever you want like a soda or water
but there's no tv and i was like
freaking
longer
i figured it would yeah and it's
american airlines it wasn't cheap i paid
1300 bucks for for
a round trip a round trip yeah
but that's so expensive what made you go
to philadelphia why did you want to go
with i just wanted to get out and just
the city of brotherly love yeah and it
was amazing
super cool city i love
how great are those suplex dudes dude
they're so fascinating
is the suplex crew they're so amazing
they're so sweet they gave me free shoes
oh yeah i do remember yeah
it's a shoe store but they have a lot of
things on their blog they they have like
their own little blocks yeah they they
know they know everybody yeah they know
they know each other they run this
[ __ ] block in philly and it's [ __ ]
amazing like they have they have one one
dude uh his name's chris he he has the
cards you know and then uh they have
like vintage shirts you know they have
like so many different things and then
the shoes so many different things on
their [ __ ] block and then they'll
walk you up a little bit they take you
to that philly cheesesteak spot no they
brought it to the the the shoe store
angelos and mike is the guy that owns i
guess suplex
he's so dope yeah mike's amazing yeah
great great and they always incredible
they're just [ __ ] amazing people so
nice how good was those philly
cheesesteaks dude they're um dude wasn't
it unreal i i couldn't i was like what
the freak is actually happening here and
i saved it and i brought it back to the
thank you
because i wanted to save something for
later when i could really enjoy it dude
i i did not
think i would [ __ ] with a philly
cheesesteak that heavy no it's so and
you've had like places from here have
you ever yeah yeah yeah and it's there's
just something i don't know something i
don't know i've never had an actual
you never have one no when i was younger
my parents used to always go to costco
and just buy a [ __ ] ton of microwavable
like freezer food like hot pockets and
they would get the freezer
hot pocket kit hell yeah
uh it would be hot pockets they do the
tv dinners or they do these frozen like
philly cheese steaks which really aren't
philly cheesesteaks they're like soggy
bread like this dried out meat and like
i don't know what the [ __ ] what do you
think about tv dinners the [ __ ]
i love dangerous
oh my god hungry man was my favorite i
love hungry hungry man yes i always got
the one with the chocolate cake oh yes
oh my god i don't care what the entree
one is always like that
i had them tv dinners i love them i get
pissed at them because that would be
relegated to one and that [ __ ] the me
after you're like oh yeah
is it terrible he was like dry on the
edges and he got cold in the middle
and thinking i was eating well
yeah oh my gosh you thought you were
eating as a kid you thought you were
killing it that one was it was the
[ __ ] boneless ribs or whatever that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] fire when i was dude
10. the salisbury steak that was my
chicken
with mashed potatoes and corn yes that
was that was the one yeah that was the
one that you consistently had also they
have you guys ever had [ __ ] the most
trash the trashiest [ __ ] on earth have
you ever had a hamburger helper i love
it i love it oh my god oh my god
i love hamburger helper dick dude
it's a delicacy in my mind so [ __ ]
nasty i guess quantity is the only thing
i care about because hamburger helper
you get a big ass [ __ ] bowl i would
never go hungry i always got all of them
wait really strolling off hamburger
healthcare you're gonna get fresh so bad
to it
fancy but also i hate i even hate
macaroni you hate macaroni and cheese
you don't like
that that changes everything yeah i
don't like macaroni chocolate from the
place
we all love it
[ __ ]
hamburger helper [ __ ] uh mac and cheese
velveeta what about mammoths
[Laughter]
how do you feel about instant noodles do
you eat those let's get like that yeah
like the top ramen it's not ramen's fire
oh i love the tomatoes fire
i used to i used to do two of the modes
yes but you know i i wasn't too heavy on
the um the seasoning the sea packets
yeah
it's super super sodium-packed
yeah yeah i remember i used to forget
sometimes when i was making my second
one i'd be eating the first one like oh
halfway through i know i want another
one and i forget to put water in it and
i just microwave the cup noodle without
the water and it like explodes yeah do
you know what i used to do
i used to crush that hoe up yes and eat
it like chips yep and then i would put
the seasoning and shake the hell up we
always have to do it
asians do that for sure
yeah it becomes so popular
but people say there's like tape worms
or something crap if you eat it wrong
that's a myth that's not good
they said the worms people used to say
that if you took out a packet of instant
ramen and you colored it with sharpie
put put it on like a piece of paper it
had like chinese writing on it it was
like propaganda we should try
worms that's just right yeah
i feel like everything i got worms yeah
you got worms you know that's from uh
that's what we're gonna call it yeah
i got words it's from dublin it's our
worm store that's what we're gonna call
it we're gonna call it
[Laughter]
no lloyd no i say we stay here look for
jobs and save up for the worm
store that was so funny who's he telling
that to what's he telling him to marry
uh in the the first scene when he's like
i got word i got worms that's the mary
in the back of the
you know my favorite part of that movie
is when uh he walks out of 7-eleven it
goes big gulps huh
well see you later
that's my favorite [ __ ] part it's
that's a lot of people's favorite parts
it's up there it's a tie it's a whole
movie with me for my favorite i want
that [ __ ] dog van
oh yeah the furry man
is that what it was an 84 sheep dog
yeah that's what they were looking for
uh
quickly on ramen freshman year of
college we would always the road trip
was always go like 45 minutes away to
the casino because like you just turned
18 yeah and they didn't have them like
close to where we were from
so you go and they had these free
buckets for like if you were playing
slot machines you get like a like a pint
bucket and we'd bring those all the time
and then they were in the dorm room so
i'd make we'd put
like just for an individual meal three
bags and crush them up and make that of
the plastic thing that i got from the
casino in the microwave a 70 cent meal
utensils included dude did you guys ever
get a crew
hey this seems like a la crosse
wisconsin thing did you ever cut up
little hot dogs and put it in the
noodles oh yeah
you gotta do it in macaroni and cheese
never ramen never in ramen okay it's
gonna be good with ramen too vienna
sausages are great spam's great
eggs whatever you get your hands on i
didn't think i would [ __ ] with spam
until one of my homies uh hawaiian dude
shouts out to eddie uh
obviously his name is eddie
he put me on game with spam he's like
bro how did he give it to you like how
did you try for the first time
yeah right
brother yeah was it in spamasubi
like the rice uh no he did he did
something to it this this guy i cheered
uh cheered with in college and he did he
was just like i got you i got you i cook
it up and then he did something too and
i was like real spanx spam is [ __ ]
good yeah you like spam we love
okay okay asians love spam yes asians
and islanders
he loves spam like this us and spam and
high cholesterol like this yeah my first
spam came from love name dropping this
joke away
uh wonder bread butter and the spam and
i was like this is [ __ ] really
amazing scram is amazing that's my
favorite red butt did you toast the
bread no
just regular
i like anything
there's no way in hell i could eat that
[ __ ] salad if the bread was not
toasted but i like eating anything
that's in that i can do arm's length of
the fridge okay okay so i could assemble
the whole sandwich not even close it
have my meal and then on your day
eating's a nuisance for me dude one of
my hobbies from jersey he used to eat i
saw he would he would get one one piece
of bread right and he would do peanut
butter and butter sandwiches and that's
what he would eat what that sounds crazy
i was like where would you do that did
you try it there or no did i try it yeah
[ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] was tight that
sounds so decadent it was it was tight
actually peanut butter and butter it
doesn't make sense but i feel like you
could do like an uncrustable like
grilled sandwich like that like make it
like a grilled cheese where you fry it
on a stovetop with some butter but the
inside's like nutella or peanut butter
yeah that's just something that [ __ ]
with a good grilled cheese you know what
i used to do in college with grilled
cheese look at us just talking about
[ __ ] i know i'm getting here right
now so i used to do this in college
i would make
grilled cheese
but i would do uh
chicken nuggets with it so i'd make a
chicken nugget grill grilled cheese you
play some salad nuggets
cordon bleu yeah
what's that uh yeah
it's like yeah okay cool no but that's
hammond
i thought uh those quarterback was like
chicken cheese chicken
yeah corbin chicken cordon bleu yeah but
yeah what is it chicken chicken corn no
i think you had it right yeah okay cool
i was like oh wait that's the i was like
that's the
school for cooking but it's the same
thing
that's the cordon bleu oh
oh right i don't know
[Laughter]
i love that we say something so
confidently that we don't know
shout out to those people thank you for
correcting us when we need to be
corrected saying something confident and
wrong is just good
yeah
yeah see it's right nice yeah and by the
way always add a slice of craft singles
to your instant ramen i guarantee it's
gonna make it ten times better oh yeah
i'm telling you mix it up
i thought i had it with a capital one
but butt crack joke
wait so you would take a slice of cheese
so once you're done like okay salt once
you're done let's say you're spam or hot
dogs whatever when it's ready to go
then i slap in a
slice of cow it has to be craft singles
right
in there all americans let it melt in a
little bit
and i usually put my egg in a little bit
raw i like it raw but you can put it in
earlier so it cooks
but that with the cheese and everything
and then you mix it up a little bit oh
my god it changes
the spam no to the to the whole noodle
ramen instant ramen oh god there is spam
in the ramen and shin ramen number one
shin ramen
that's enough
ramen black
yeah black is probably like the highest
quality it's like this is like the real
real deal [ __ ] yes i mean
it's still cheap but it's it's like the
better ones of the cheap ones that's
what that that's the one yeah that's
cheap that's the best if you look at the
nutritional effects on that
i know you would be like
you'd be upset with yourself
yeah that's my favorite the sodium on
those [ __ ] insane it's like nine
hundred insane and i will slurp up
that's like persevering like it's
nothing
did you guys know a serving was half of
a bag yeah yeah that's [ __ ] just
yeah
and tell me how much tell me how fat i'm
gonna be 1500 grams of sodium also i
don't care about what the nutritional
facts is i'm also the hormone the whole
bag is 1800 milligrams exactly that when
you know you're eating this you know
what you're doing yeah i know you're
gonna you know what you get involved
with it just enjoy it's for it's for
taste yeah like i'm not eating a serving
of hot cheetos i know i'm eating a bag
of hot cheetos and i'm saying so i don't
give a [ __ ] anymore is that is that the
spicy one that he pulled up okay so it
looks spicy but it's not that spicy
it looks spicy it's not that spicy this
is also from a korean man i feel like
korean pretty spicy no i i suck at spice
kind of so i think the spiciest is
probably thai in in i was going to say
india yeah yeah i think that's that's
fair too
along came polly
anybody thing i remember from a long
game probably is uh best man's here and
he [ __ ] slips in the opening and then
i remember uh
when he's playing basketball
oh yeah uh philip seymour hoffman oh and
then uh i remember his wife rest in
peace
or his original girlfriend cheated on
him with
the guy on the beach yeah deborah
messing cheated on him with uh hank
azaria yeah hey gazaria yeah
yeah yeah he's like you guys here for
scuba
yeah but he like the whole premise is uh
he's a really like
guy doesn't take any risks and then he
starts dating this kind of gypsy girl
jennifer anderson she takes some indian
food so he goes and obviously he gets
really bad stomach problems because it's
so spicy yo ben steller's a goat
zoolander the other day
that would be so dumb funny you're
hitting my wheelhouse
oh that's your movement oh i [ __ ]
meet the fockers
some great films i met owen wilson
yeah yeah the dallas mall
uh we were we were there for a cheer
competition and a few girls on my we
went to the mall
like the day before or whatever just to
do something and a couple girls on my
team
uh got caught stealing
i did not expect that turn and then so
when wilson was like watching security
and the cops
uh take
the girls on my team and then i was like
oh wilson
and then you guys uh took mushrooms and
rappelled down mount vesuvius
[Laughter]
owen wilson is like the silly matthew
mcconaughey yeah yeah i heard he's got
like a [ __ ] child he's like not um
taken care of this is a semi
someone just broke my heart about owen
wilson i won't you guys that's how i
feel about jackie chan with his daughter
jackie chan
yeah he's got kids yeah jackie chan
hell yes her name is jackie chan
but yeah jackie chan has a son with his
wife and then he uh was caught like
having an affair with someone else had a
daughter and basically said i'm not
taking care of the daughter and i'm not
going to give her a penny of my money so
he's kind of like a dead beat
but i still love jackie chan i i have
such a special friend
yeah so she is a
lesbian lesbian yeah
where is she does she subscribe to your
only fans
no i don't think so i don't think she
does is that her
yeah i believe that's her
so young
god i wish they made another rush hour i
love those movies they're so funny so
good chris tucker and jackie chan is the
duo i feel like i never
i never asked for but always wanted this
is the perfect time because like
obviously like those guys they can be in
it but they can't be the main guys
they're too old they can yeah they need
a hand and top gun they need a hand and
we can't have our new
it's like 21 jump street
yes exactly remember it was originally
johnny depp and who was the other guy
[ __ ] uh i know right
anybody know who the other guy was no
who's the other guy at 21 jump street
the original
the original
but then channing tatum and jonah hilton
that [ __ ] is fun with those
i in that first one i loved uh dave
franco he was so [ __ ] oh my god dave
franco plays such a good like nerdy
bully yeah so good i love how
progressive
how
progressive it's so funny
oh that's the other guy
yep that was like the main uh the other
main character peter de louise
i dave franco's like i love the way you
uh you [ __ ] up that soccer game
organized sports or fascist [ __ ]
and it makes perfect sense because he's
a uh palo alto kid he's like from
stanford rich like bougie super
progressive neighborhood it's like super
on point it's so accurate it's not even
acting at that point obviously it's just
rip to ray leota yeah r.i.p ray leota
rip ray liotta
wow johnny depp was such a babe
everybody
go home and take some chantix
somewhat oh my gosh the chantix thing
have you seen that with ray leota no
we're having it's insanely funny chandix
commercial yeah what is chanting chantix
is a medication to get you to stop
smoking but it has just some of the most
aggressive side effects
of any drug like lots of times they'll
rat off a lot uh but i mean
the chantix commercial is the
epitome of it and you know how um
uh
the guy who does all the impressions um
he'll do like bill maher uh
[ __ ] he's super funny and he does it
kyle dunnigan kyle donaghy he does a
hilarious real ray leo to fake chantix
commercial but the real one is just as
good
just chantix railio to chantix
c-h-a-n-t-i-x
c-h-a
yeah there you
oh
go
there's kyle
you came up first sad kind of
kind of sounds kind of cool
just seems smart
[Music]
i tried cold turkey i tried the pasta
look at his eyes they didn't work for me
i didn't think anything was going to
work for me until i tried chantix
enchantix along with support
until i tried chantix reduced my urge to
smoke i needed that to quit
it looks like you've got eyeliner with
or without chantix or just his eyes
withdrawal symptoms some people like
changes in behavior are thinking
aggression hostility agitation depressed
mood or suicidal like what the [ __ ]
serious side effects may include
seizures new or worse harder blood
vessel problems sleepwalking or allergic
respiration
tell your health care provider if you've
had depression or other mental health
problems decrease alcohol use while
taking chantix use caution when driving
or operating machinery the most common
side effect is nausea
behind me talk to you but at least
you're not smoking i know at least
i'd rather deal with withdrawals or
smoke williams does a bit on
medications like that or like stuff yeah
about the side effects
it's almost it that kind of joke about
side effects goes back a long way but
the way they do it's so slow there and
he's like
so many too yeah depression anger it's
like dramatically funny because like
i feel like they do that to make you
overlook
these of course the the side effects
yeah
they're using imagery everything nothing
worked then i drive [ __ ]
[Laughter]
let's change
why would you want to do that
hey i'm ray and i quit [ __ ] smoking
with [ __ ] chantings so try chantix
yeah you can't swear i'm ray and i stop
smoking with [ __ ] chances you should
[ __ ] get chantix
i'm just talking to myself it's weird
you know
if i got a scene i'm doing i you know
i'll beat you i'll beat you in the
[ __ ] head if you don't try [ __ ]
chanting
that's how you sell a product
you know
yeah
i mean [ __ ] the one of the greatest
actors well he has a cigarette in his
hand
and then later you can cgi the cigarette
out what are we shooting
i tried
oh
all right man
when's this episode dropped guys come
see me in london
i'll be there thursday where will you
performing at the 100 club which is a
legendary club oasis performed there
heck yeah sex pistols
uh buzzcocks metallica
um the rolling stones did like a secret
show there one time
uh a lot you know oh damn i got a lot of
tour dates hey good for me huh
hashtag books
[Laughter]
with the t at the end and then uh and
then at the end of the month
meatball and i will he won't be going on
stage maybe i'll maybe i'll bring
meatball on stage and then throw him in
the crowd you guys can catch him
june 24th yeah 25th i'll be at uh the
comedy connection in providence rhode
island so you could bench press him
again yeah i was just like
so if he straightens his back
thank you guys thank you guys for the
love and support
oh yeah yeah
george what do you got all right so i
got a couple daily news things to show
you oh no uh or just for yeah
yeah just everybody got to play and i
ain't going to show you all [ __ ]
georgie he's ready
don't be discouraged though keep those
in the holster
uh so i have my youtube channel go
george go right great vlogs i saw the
editing i was super impressed i told
jordan sorry the power of thick boy
getting me this knowledge
i also have uh
my instagram go george harris48 you can
see all my cute pictures cute nice
and it's george's birthday tomorrow
right tomorrow is my 23rd birthday
happy birthday happy early birthday yeah
happy early birthday george thank you
guys uh and nick will be running his new
club
club freeway on the
i'm going to try to get footage for you
guys next week i'm going i'm going to
get a great scooter and a gopro uh just
so you guys are going to be hiring
influencers for those like club
promotions oh yeah
i can't wait to see the flyers
speaking of flyers that's actually was
gonna plug i've been talking about this
uh fight between um senator mitch
mcconnell and my friend dylan um we have
yet to hear from the senator's office
but i did commission uh really amazing
if you want to look this up needing art
uh
they're just a really good they make
fight posters and they're gonna do a a
fight poster for mitch and dylan um
check out more info on that another
podcast show we'll have updates they do
like legit post yeah cause they have
because they're like the ufc spends like
no money on graphic artists it must be
like [ __ ] some intern who's like yeah
i'll do it for you they're always shitty
so he always like creates them for the
events and they're always like
way way doper yeah but uh i cannot wait
to see what he comes up with with the uh
mitch mcconnell it it it's uh
no politics fight night presented by the
united states senate and another podcast
show he said no policies
that's the name of the car so another
pocket issue
so
i got some stuff going on now
well as you can see there there's my
instagram but it's so it's
shinsuyi but so my sponsor into the am
who should probably sponsor this show
eventually we'll see they're actually
working with me on my very own
uh t-shirt graphic tee oh so yeah it's
incredible like in this video i can't
believe it's happening so there's like
different options there's one two three
and four that we're going over like the
designs it's all about camping and
fishing that's what i love to do the
most
and sip in as well so there's a few
different designs if you go to my
instagram you can see them help help me
to pick which design looks the best and
we'll move forward with that design and
it's also on my youtube channel too
that's awesome yeah oh no we should have
looked at those uh
are are they up there should we show
them i mean i think uh georgia just
showed him right now oh there's one that
one's yeah that one
they're all involved
two one that you want and that's three
which one one three and f4 that's the
lantern with the scene in the background
number one don't go vote on his page go
vote let me know yeah
appreciate it comment on this uh post
yes
thanks george where are you oh yeah uh
hi uh you can find me on instagram at
teen my only fans at teen and then i
randomly do vlogs now yeah it's been fun
i record basically recording back to the
vlogs yeah that's awesome yeah it's fun
i feel like vlogging is such
so much more fun when i don't have to
edit stuff
oh yeah oh my god it's so much fun that
is so i don't know how to how that sucks
and i feel like it takes forever to do
it yeah and so like props to you guys
for like taking hours to edit i don't
know how you do that
i'm too [ __ ] boring to do a vlog no
you're not you weirdo
you're perfectly you did one in london
it'd be dope oh dude the london vlog was
sick yeah wait bruh do you know what i
do on a regular basis what same thing
dope [ __ ] you're okay let me let me take
a while again
you wake up at six in the morning you
journal
you take a shower you either go to
i don't think you go to zoo and weight
lift anymore but you used to too much
yeah i think that's too stressful for
you i feel like after you journal you're
having like a breakfast or a lunch you
hang out with toby you do your evening
hikes and then you do a set at like
don't tell comedy or the comedy store
and then you're at home preparing for a
podcast the next day
that's a great vlog right there what you
do that day in and day out i can see why
he's like okay i got one television the
journal the journaling is a lot of hours
mm-hmm that's a b-roll baby yeah
yeah
dear diary dear diary is that how you
start yourself
i just write the date and then i go you
know i've been feeling this mm-hmm do
you want a computer to or just you right
now i can't do a computer oh okay
i had to write it if i did it on the
computer i'd just be like too robotic
yeah that's how i do it now i started
journaling yeah i get my feather and my
ink your quilt
[Music]
do you do one of these where you like
lick it yeah yeah and then you put it
i haven't gotten to the point do it
where i do it consistently yet but like
i start to start it yeah i have here and
there and uh we all have awesome i've
heard people say and it was hard for me
too it's like how how do you start it is
start like dear diary you don't know
what to do i've heard
um and this really helped me just uh
start saying what you did yesterday
and what uh what you want to do today
and that'll lead you in all these
different
yeah that's a good one i never thought
of it that way i just kind of be talking
[ __ ] yeah you know
you're in the groove though like you're
if you're someone who hasn't started i
got like a crate full of like all these
old journals like that are filled up so
do you ever look back at them or what i
don't look back at so i always delete i
always delete it after i write it really
let's just just so i can put it out
there i won't delete it
i won't i was sorry i won't get rid of
them because
i when i first started journaling
uh which was like
when i started getting super heavy into
it or just
getting into it it was like 2013
and
i ripped out all the pages in that
journal and threw them away because it
was too tough and i i don't regret that
i did it but i'm really upset that i
didn't what would you do
but what would you say would you
actually want to look back
would you want to look back at like if
you had it right now would you look back
at that stuff you know there's times
where i have okay so then that and it's
kind of crazy you see like the
progress of it of the individual self
can i pitch something to you with your
journals
i feel like down the line maybe not
right now maybe like five ten years from
now when you're comfortable smithsonian
yes
absolutely absolutely
the chapel
yeah
before you hit the smithsonian i do
think that you should write something
out and like create a show around your
life like the rock or like joe coy's
doing like when you're more established
you're a little older you could look at
it through a lens of like that was my
younger self in my younger years like
everybody eats
i'll call it the pebble the pebble
because of the rock
oh i think you're gonna have to do
something else oh damn it
the questions
yeah i think it's like
since i moved to l.a
i think i have like eight that i've
filled up so far within the past four
years damn you should call game of
thrones
i should
i got a name for it
yep can i play you chappelle in the show
yeah go ahead [ __ ] i've always wanted
long hair yeah
just so i can head bang at shows and be
like i know that's so much fun i'll get
a weave with my hair back and forth
don't break your neck like she did
though
oh yes you did all right uh thank you
guys for tuning in london i'll see you
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you